[Music]
kelly wrote me a note on the board up
here that i look to see like which line
the calls are in says annelise boston
dating mom's ex-boyfriend please tell me
that's not right uh unfortunately
it is are you serious what are you doing
what happened
[Music]
it's so hard to fall you float like a
cannonball
what's up everybody
this is john with the dr john delony
show so glad you're here don't know why
i'm yelling we're all in the same little
headphone space
so glad you're here hey if you haven't
listened to damian rice oh record from
way back in the day
it's just called oh
man
right when this podcast is over
get on spotify and listen to it it's so
good so good hey on the show we're
talking about mental health
relationships we're talking about
educate anything and everything that's
going on in your
life we got a
a show full of calls
that's kind of what we do here james
good to see you glad you made it
james is doing the uh cool producer
thing right now where he has the
headphones around his neck
it's pumping directly into his uh his
arteries
it's the kind of producer he is oh he's
got him back on
things in here called speakers so i can
hear through the speakers too
you and your techno wizardry
speakers ridiculous headphones people
let's go to kate in fort myers what's up
kate
hello how are we doing
i'm doing well how are you we're
figuring it out
figuring it out what's up
um my
issue
is that my
i let things bother me that are outside
the realm of my influence
me too tell me what you're struggling
with
um well my father passed away 20 years
ago okay and ever since then my brother
has used this opportunity to
financially exploit my mother
he has a lot of influence over her
how is he exploiting her
um well just she just told me a story
last week where she had given him a
check for
thirty uh thirty dollars
a blank check she gave it to him because
he needed um
to get a license for his dog well he
took that check and he wrote it out for
six hundred dollars oh
so he's stealing ten years ago yeah
about ten years ago
her house burned down and she got
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
from the insurance
he slowly but surely took money from her
from that toward the point where
there's no money left he kept saying
i'll go buy the wood and repair the
house i'll go buy this piece of
equipment and fix the house up i'll you
know and he just slowly but surely
drained all that money from her
so
what what part about that can you not
control
or is she just allowing it because if
i'm you yeah i'd call the cops i'd get
an attorney i'd get i'd
i'd raise all kinds of
sideways barn fires to get in there on
that i don't
what part can you not control unless
you've talked to her and she says yeah
well that's just your brother is that
what's happening
yes she keeps saying
well he's gonna fix that house for me
someday he owes me that money and he's
going to
take care of it and in her will
she has left
him
the only asset she has left which is her
120 acre farm
she's left that to him in the will
why not
why not me because i'm a boy
the boy gets the farm the boy gets the
farm and we've talked about it and she
even has said what's the girl get the
plates
uh the girl gets the plates yes the girl
gets placed um
why
it's the i want to keep it in the gr in
the name the lab i won't say my last
name um yeah i want to keep it in the
you know and i don't have that same last
name whatever it's whatever i'm not i
don't want anything from her yeah i
don't want anything i've told her
you know use your money on you
spend it on you
you know
so when this thing when this thing goes
sideways when ultimately your brother
has completely
poked enough holes in the bottom of this
um
fish tank for there to be no more water
left there's no more money
all right are you going to be
responsible for taking care of mom
is she going to move in no
no my other my other sister will i mean
i will if my other sister yeah there's
three girls and one boy in the family
okay all
of us girls you know try to help her try
to and it's
i let go of it about 10 years ago but
recently she started helping out another
person who was taking advantage of her
her nephew
who's moved in with her and is taking
advantage her and that's what got kind
of brought it up again
and i just i want to be able to
have a relationship with her
but it's so hard when she won't set any
boundaries i feel like i have really
good healthy boundaries i set with
people and i want to cut her out of my
life right i want to be there for her
but then she'll just drop this you know
a story like she just told me the other
day she drops a story on me oh i gave
him a check and he
wrote it up for 600. well i closed that
account so it's all okay now and i'm
like but it's not okay yeah it's just
it's the sun
robbing his mother i i mean
in the
of course any kind of being a thief is
being a thief right um and not telling
the truth it's not telling truth and
blah blah blah but stealing from your
mother man
you know what i mean like that's yeah
that's next level yeah um he even he
even
maybe it was 15 years ago right after my
dad passed away
he threatened suicide
you know so because
you know oh no who's going to help me
out kind of thing so i think she's
always got that in the back of her head
that if she doesn't help him out
and the worst part of that well not that
that's not bad enough but the worst part
of it is
her mother committed suicide oh yikes
she knows the pain of that and it's like
if that's his undue influence over her
for the last 15 years is you know i
think he just kind of drops that little
sounds like your mom's had a lot of big
hurt in her life
and
she has developed some pretty
um miraculous slash pathological ways of
segmenting people's behaviors so that
she can
keep people in her life and
um unfortunately the good kids
the three daughters who are
still coming around and still trying to
be supportive
y'all bear the emotional weight that she
can't carry
because she just fluffs it off right
so
two important things here one is
mom is a proxy right now you haven't
made peace with your brother
so you either need to have your
conversation with your brother
and let everything be said that you want
to be said
um
write him a letter and say all the
things that you are stealing from our
mother you should be ashamed of yourself
i know she raised you better than like
you need to have that conversation with
him all three of your sisters need to
have that conversation with him whatever
um or
in some families that can happen other
families that can't so i won't speak
into which one and you're you you know
your sisters and your brother
my guess is just talking to you for a
few minutes if that conversation would
have been fruitful you'd have had that
years ago and so my guess is that's not
a fruitful conversation
if it's not
you have to make peace with the haunting
fact that part of what made your brother
made you
and when our brothers and sisters do
things that hurt other people by
extension we're like that's kind of can
i do that right it's kind of it's this
exten you're going to have to
cut that tie
you're going to have to put up a really
firm boundary i don't talk about my
brother i don't acknowledge this guy
he is a crook and he steals from my
mother
and so the only way i can preserve my
dignity and my treating other people
with respect is to say that person does
not exist i i am a person who always
leaves um an unlocked door for somebody
to return
but that person that's them i i can't
continue to chase you down right
and my gut tells me is when you make
peace with that whatever your choice is
there
then the conversation with your mom when
she starts telling about the nephew
saying mom you know i don't think he
should be living here
i think he's stealing from you and i
will not have a conversation about him
let's talk about something else
okay right and so that's you
you're not taking control of your
feelings what you're doing is you're
taking control of the on and off ramp
you're putting a toll stop there
so that when that thing gets when a car
tries to drive through you're stopping
it before it even gets going
right see what i'm saying that that is
the only way i've found to stop stuff
when i'm
worrying about things i can't control i
can't stop worrying about russia and
ukraine so i have to cut off my access
to the information about it on a 24 7
365 basis see what i see what i'm doing
do you talk to your sisters about this
yes
all the time and my they both live very
close to her i'm
1200 miles away so i get you know
i get the stories from my mom i you know
but i also get them from
my sisters and then that's all we end up
talking about for
you know 20 minutes
what he's doing yeah i think i mean
that's the further extension of the
boundaries is talking to your sister
either somebody either there's an
intervention and the three daughters go
sit with mom and say we want this crook
out of your house um and then she might
say
well forget you guys i want you all out
of my house and that's one of those
relational risks that you got to take
when you're trying to save somebody
um
i don't know enough to know whether
she's
desperate for someone to come in and
save her or if she doesn't give you all
that power my guess is if y'all had that
power you would have used it by now but
the worst part about boundaries with
family is
boundaries come with a risk and the risk
is they could say no
bye and walk away and that's a gut
wrenching and
i'm telling you you're trying to
preserve a relationship with your mother
which is noble and good but you also
can't see her you can't stand by and
watch what she allows herself to be held
under water by a criminal son and a
criminal nephew and so it may be the
best way to protect yourself is to
extricate yourself from the situation
turn your like say i'm not having these
conversations anymore
um i don't think it's beyond getting
with your two sisters and calling an
attorney and seeing if she's got the
ability to care for herself with the way
they're draining her
or whether it's worth getting the
authorities involved or at least having
an attorney write your brother and write
your nephew a letter that says if
another dollar comes out right your mom
may say no i can do what i want to with
my money and that's just heartbreaking
and that's
adults can do what adults can do
but it may be worth throwing a grenade
to see what happens that's probably what
i would do just because i
i don't know i don't have a hard time
taking no for an answer sometimes but
just hear me say this i'm sorry this is
hard hard hard we'll be right back
hey john delony here i say it all the
time there are no tips or tricks or
hacks when it comes to living a better
life it all comes down to being
intentional with the practices you do
every day and the most important
practice you can do to improve your
mental and physical health is to start
getting enough quality sleep i know this
from personal experience and from the
data and for me good sleep starts with a
world-class mattress it's why my family
sleeps on dream cloud mattresses whether
you're a back sleeper a stomach sleeper
an edge of the bed sleeper or just a
weird sleeper right or you have to make
room for your dog dream cloud's combo of
gel memory foam and coil technology
keeps you comfortable all night and
dream cloud is running their biggest
offer ever exclusively for our listeners
499 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's a total
of
749 dollars in accessories and savings
pillows mattress protector luxury sheets
all of it it's time to change your sleep
and change your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new savings and your
new mattress today
all right we're back let's go to
annalise in boston what's up
hi dr jones how are you i'm good okay so
kelly wrote me a note on the board up
here that i look to see like which line
the calls are in
and it says is it analyst or annalise
uh annelise beautiful name okay says
annelise boston
dating mom's ex-boyfriend please tell me
that's not right
uh unfortunately
it is are you serious what are you doing
what happened
yeah this wasn't a situation obviously i
ever thought i would be in and i tried
not to
be in this situation but basically um
okay
i want to hear all of this
okay um so
i'm currently 23 years old i'm a college
student and
my boyfriend is
50 years old and he dated my mom
um he started dating my mom
eight years ago um they broke up
around five years ago they did it for
like three years and um so they started
dating when you were 15 before you could
drive
yes did you know him then
um
they dated for three years sure you hung
out
yeah um actually he's like notable
because my parents divorced when i was
12 and he was the first guy after
there's a divorce that she felt
um that she could introduce me and my
two older half brothers too so and
introduce her she did him she did right
okay so fast forward they dated for
three years and broke up so this wasn't
like they went out once
this is like
yeah that's what's up and then
how did you run into this guy
um so i went away
you know after i graduated high school i
went away to college in another state
and um it was just a kind of bad
experience um i wasn't doing well in my
classes it was expensive college um and
you know i i didn't really make that
many friends so i decided to transfer to
a college
closer to home that was cheaper and i
was just in a really bad place in my
life i gained like 20 pains and i
applied for an internship i really
wanted didn't get it and the nation's
community you know you should go out and
just
just like
go to industry events and just
like network and just talk to people and
just learn a lot and during one of those
industry events i bumped into him and
his silver thinning here just caught
your attention and you were like oh yeah
like how did that even happen i'm in i'm
in my early 40s
like when i run into 23 year olds now i
feel like i like
it's i don't know what to say
right it it feels awkward because the
because of the age gap so i'm just
trying to think of myself
a decade from now just
into an industry event
and being like oh look
23 year old that i'm gonna give that a
go i can't even wrap my head around that
so walk me through how you all met
um
so um
at the industry event or just like
i'm just this is purely 100
almost all the time i ask questions to
get more data from my response
i just need to know like how this
happened this is this is me taking your
time just for personal gain all
listeners you can just hit the 15 second
little spinny thing i just got to know
how this guy
got you interested in him
um so maybe he's a 50 year old smoke
show maybe yeah okay sorry i interrupted
you go ahead
so when he was dating my mom we only met
like three times then um
like he was basically like
i didn't really have that much of an
impression of him because i felt like
you know he's my mom's boyfriend blah
blah blah but
take me to take me to the industry event
you're in a big hotel lobby
with all the little booths and stuff and
then you see this
the smoking hot 50 year olds like what's
up ladies and you said yep that like how
what was the move how did it work
it didn't happen like that um i was with
a friend from college who also wanted to
build this thing and then i basically
was walking um i was like my eyes were
going towards like a door because i
wanted to
go to like some other
room and then
i saw this man who was like looking at
me and then i had to like do a double
take because it's been a couple of years
and i was like oh no it's it's him and
then um obviously it would look
ridiculous if i just like if he was like
saying hi to me and i walked away so
you know we started talking and then my
mom keeps telling me no
and then you started talking and then
just
man okay so i'll stop picking on you so
let's fast forward
so how long have you all been together
now
um
we started dating like a year slightly
over a year ago
and your mom doesn't know it's like
yeah she does not know and i've only
told like
a couple of friends and they were all
like this is not what i meant by getting
out there like of all the men in the
world yep you have good friends um
so
how can i help
you've told me a great you've told me a
great yarn uh how how can i help
my mom keeps telling me no but
keep going go ahead go ahead go ahead
so and yeah just one hundred dollars to
say i didn't um it you know we also
after that event we bumped into each
other a couple other times and then he
invited me to go to some other place and
i was like this is probably wrong so i
said no and then he showed up to
my apartment and convinced me to go with
him and that's when things started
happening and um i just i just don't
know what to do
at this point because
it's like first of all i feel very
guilty because
um when i was depressed my mom finally
told me why they broke up and it was
because
she got pregnant and then
he said
like uh he's
he does stuff in architecture so he says
like my buildings are my children i
don't want any children so that's why
they broke up
and then
you know and now he's saying like
basically you know he's had a lot of
health issues his dad who was like the
center of his world died so
um
he says that this isn't about
your mom i do like you and then he says
but i don't want you to do anything
you're not comfortable with but i just
don't see how
you know i feel like i'm just in way
over my head
yes okay so number one saying that out
loud i'm i appreciate it um
so what i will tell you on this side of
the fence on this side of 30 let me just
say that
um
the phrase you're in over your head i
think is is apt
and i'm glad that you see that and more
importantly you feel that right your
body tells you something's not right the
reason i know you're not okay with this
is that you don't tell your friends i
mean you're not you're not holding his
hand in public you're not out and about
this is something that is a source of
shame for you and you haven't told your
mom who you're close to
and that that's those secrets are
are killing you right they're i mean
they're eating it from the inside out
and
quite honestly in this call i'm going to
tell you i'm sorry this is all fun and
games until
it sounds like you are being pressured
to participate in a relationship that
you are objectively not comfortable with
is that true
yeah i just i just you know i
it's just
i i feel like i you know he's like the
first person i've ever had like a
serious relationship with and um hey let
let me be very clear let me be very
clear this is not a serious relationship
you are being taken advantage of
okay
no let me rephrase that this is very
serious for you
not so much for him
like i'm feeling i'm feeling rage
growing in my chest that this man is
taking advantage of you like he is and i
know you're 23 and the whole world's
gonna say you're an adult and this and
that
um
you're in over your head
and this is this is a mess
so
tell me what happens if you just broke
up with him today you just said hey i
don't ever want to see you again
um thanks but no thanks i wish you the
best life in your architectural baby
buildings
um you you
what would happen what would happen to
you what would happen to him walk me
through it
um
i definitely would feel like
uh i
feel like the world's kind of a little
bit ending not in like that dramatic way
just like i would really need to
definitely not see anybody for
like a week or something two weeks and
and i think he would be because you know
he told me a lot about
you know how
like the death of a father really
affects you he feels so lonely like
yeah
that is children honey that is part of
the game that's the part of the scam
he's running on you
yes losing your father is intensely
lonely no question
um
using that as
hooks in a
23 year old
is
just not cool
that and that's to put it as mildly as
possible i'm really trying to watch my
mouth here
um
you aren't his caretaker you can't quote
unquote make him feel better
um you aren't all he's got left in the
world
those things that he tells you
those are that's a move
and i'm sick to my stomach that he's
dragged you through this
what happens if you sit down and again
hear me if if you were to end this
relationship there's no question it'd be
devastating for you okay
um
this guy's clearly uh i mean you clearly
care about him he's probably been really
nice to you
um
you'll have an intimate connection y'all
are a high a connected group you've been
dating for a year right
and that's heavy and hard is he your
first true real love
he um
because yeah he's actually like the
first guy
i don't know if i can say this on the
show you say whatever you want we're way
past that yeah
he's the first yeah makes
annalisa make sure you're talking to
your phone okay
okay yeah uh he's the first guy i've
slept with because
um you know in college i just felt like
i'm pretty average looking and then i
didn't want to do it with anybody
because i felt like you know everybody's
drunk and blah blah blah it's just like
and i didn't feel like the first choice
and i just didn't want to be
like in that situation so listen to me
listen to me listen to me okay
there's a lot of emotional hooks in here
this is a
do not pass go don't collect 200
i want you before um
this we're having this call at the
beginning of a week i don't know when
it's going to release but we're at the
beginning of a week
before the next 48 hours goes by i want
you to reach out to a counselor
okay with a professional to walk you
through this is going to be a mess okay
will you commit to doing that
yeah i just don't know like
because you know i really love my mom
and
i know that
i i don't want to keep hiding this from
her you know that's right um
oh man
yeah you're gonna need to you gotta have
to have some hard
conversations and
you're operating from a place of
um
you're worth more than the way you have
been told uh
you're worth more than
how much you've been told you're worth
and
you have
infinite value and infinite strength you
just don't know it and i want you and
people have not given you that they
haven't told you that they haven't
walked too long and giving you tools and
showing it to you and so i really really
want you to sit down with a professional
and counselor
because you've got some hard
conversations ahead of you
either
i am out to lunch and totally wrong and
i could be
um i think it's a disastrous idea that
you're dating
a man that your mom dated for three
years i think it's a disaster okay i
don't see a way this ends well
some of the things you are telling me
are
cornerstone uh very predatory
i don't like it
if he wants to call my show i'm happy to
talk to him and maybe he just found the
love of his life who happens to be 25
years younger 27 years younger and knock
your lights out great
um
i i
cool
um
but man you mix in a pregnancy you mix
in a pregnancy termination you mix in
three years
you have fractured um your choices
you've chosen to fracture a relationship
with your mom and he's making it really
really hard so you're either going to
have to have a hard conversation with
her or a hard conversation with him and
you need some tools for both of those
and that's why i want you to go talk to
somebody because here's the thing
there's other things happening right now
that you and i would need to get into
that's going to be
exceed my capacity to help you on this
show
but hear me say i don't have any problem
people are dating 25 years younger
that's all fine i absolutely
think there's some predators you don't
just bump into somebody
in a giant city multiple times unless
they want to and then you tell them no
then they knock on your apartment door
and all of a sudden they're taking your
virginity they're all all these then
telling you well you're the last all of
it all of it
something's off please on elise
please
go call a counselor and say i want to
talk to you about keeping secrets
i'm in a mess to use your words i'm over
my head
and i don't have a path out and i need
some help and let them walk alongside
you
okay
we love you
wow
what a mess we'll be right back
hey dr john deloney here let's talk
about sleep my friends it's one of the
best things you can do to improve your
mental health and your physical health
in one of the biggest areas we neglect
it's time to change that and for me
getting good deep restorative sleep
starts with a good mattress that's why
my family sleeps on dream cloud
mattresses right now dream club is
running their biggest offer ever
exclusively for our listeners 499 bucks
and accessories plus an additional 250
cash discount that's like
749 dollars in accessories and savings
pillows mattress protector luxury sheets
all of it it's time to get the rest your
body and mind needs because your mental
health matters this means prioritize
your sleep it means get seven to nine
hours of sleep each night that means
ditching the ten-year-old hand-me-down
mattress that you got from your weird
aunt a long time ago go to
dreamcloudsleep.comcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code deloney to get your
new mattress and enjoy your savings and
start sleeping today
all right we're back
ah that last calls in my guts man it's
got me all ugh
don't forget to share the show
and uh give it a great review on the on
the on on itunes
wherever they get podcasts
i don't i don't even
let's just go to diane
here's a little story about jack and
diane in dallas texas what's up diane
hey john how are you doing i'm still
recovering from that last call how are
you
i'm doing well thank you so much good
what is up how can i help you're
bringing me back to life i appreciate
you
oh you're very very welcome so so to
give me some actual background i was
born and raised in a small town in texas
and now i live in the dallas area so
i've been going
from my hometown for over 20 years but
you're still hey but you're still in the
motherland you're still in the
motherland yes yes yes i'm only about
three and a half to four hours from from
the hometown
and raised in okay i was born and raised
in texas and they told us that al qaeda
is waiting for us at the oklahoma border
and so you're still in texas so you're
still safe right
yes okay i've been doing very well all
right thank you all right so what's up
so my siblings stayed in my small small
town and even in the houston area and so
they they continue with this very
traditional and very religious mindset
that is very very similar to my parents
and then john there's me you know good
good old me i have marched to the beat
of my own drum i took what what my
parents gave me and i got rid of
whatever didn't serve me okay knowing
very well that i am the one who is the
the creator of my own life okay
so for the past two years my sister has
said that she wants to be closer to me
and the thought of being closer make
makes me cringe now i will say whenever
covet happened the actual blessing was
that i could play that kovitz
talk right into your phone okay i'm
starting to lose you yeah
yes okay so
so yes so i was able able to play that
copic card all through covet well as you
know the covert numbers they're they're
calming down and so she's starting these
conversations about us spending time
now john we don't have the same views we
don't have the same interest lifestyle
hobbies preferences
i don't care to hear
bible bible scripture stuff i don't care
to pray pray with her i don't care to
hear whatever the lord has quote led her
to tell me
and so i
want to be closer to her and have a
workable relationship but at the same
time i i notice that when i'm spending
time with her that i'm the one who is
surviving and i don't want to feel like
i have to tolerate her in in order to
make her happy
so what do i do
oh man you're awesome you are awesome
okay um
this is going to be um simple
but very very hard okay
it's gonna be simple like how do you
lose weight diet and exercise cool
thanks genius right very very hard to do
um two important things
and i got one question for you before i
start doling it out um
does she want to move next to you or get
close to you or reconnect with you as
some sort of missionary venture or she
dismiss her sister
what what i hear her saying is
that she cherishes whatever relationship
we had when i was in college which which
i was like 21 22 then and i'm 45 years
old now so my my lifestyle and my views
have changed drastically and she's still
still holding on to to what is no longer
okay so here's an important conversation
a
deeply important conversation
that will be both challenging and
incredibly liberating for you you ready
yes i want you to write her a letter
with
the last 20 years
i remember our time in college we went
to
fill in the blank we did this we shared
this
here's how i have changed over the last
20 years
ah here's my views on a couple of
important topics that i know are going
to be hard for you
i do not like it when people come at me
with their spirituality that i haven't
invited into my life
um i have different beliefs now
i have hung out with different people
all right my life looks different and
this is what it looks like
now
this would be best
if y'all got together for a meal and you
read this letter to her
ah okay
because and and here's why this is
important
um if you read it to her she's gonna
want to interject well hold on let me
and say i need to finish this letter
here's what you're doing when you have
this conversation in this way
you are establishing
boundaries you are establishing strength
here
that i am in charge of the conversation
that i'm choosing to have at this table
if you want to continue to remain at
this table in relationship with me
i'm going to finish this letter and it's
subtle and it's small and it's not rude
and it's not ugly and it's not you
throwing things
but it's you just establishing
before we have any more conversation
before i'm going to hear you we're going
to finish this so we all know we're on
the same page
now take all of the
her coming at you with all of her
whatever spirituality and conspiracy all
the stuff
would you want to hang out with her if
she quit doing that
it's possible and then i i often ask
myself unless i was hanging out with her
what would we do considering that we are
we don't have interest in the same
things okay so let me i'm going to tell
you something hard okay sounds like
you've been through 20 years of
deconstruction which is
yeah okay so yeah but listen and this is
this is me coming at you hard okay you
cool okay
um
there's a great theologian named rich
mullins who says
christians are often as proud of the
things they don't have
as non-christians are the things they do
have
meaning
he was noting that somebody can be
driving around in a 1981 honda accord
that's duct taped together and it's
barely running
and look at somebody in a lexus and go
oh my gosh i can't believe how many
hungry people they could feel i can't
feed i can't believe it would ever be so
arrogant and pompous to drive that car
and what he would say is that is the
exact attitude of the person that
wouldn't bought that expensive lexus and
looks down on the person in the crummy
car for having less
same exact issue just on the other side
of the barbell you hear what i'm saying
now when people go through extreme
deconstruction i've been there too
oh i've been there multiple times it's
awesome right uh when i've
what happens often
is you develop a
superiority well i've thought through
this i've actually read science i've
come to this i
and you slowly build yourself up to
where you feel as though you're looking
down on
right
and what i'll tell you is that is a
lonely dangerous identity to to hold
because your cond your deconstruction
will one day be deconstructed too not
that you're going to go back to the
faith of your child or anything like
that
but anytime you plant a flag on top of a
pile of rocks the pile will ultimately
slip out from underneath you
that's the that's that's the beauty of
it right and so
i would love to see you come at your
sister with a very humble spirit
because my guess is there's a lot of
deep wounds there
and if you if your sister's not safe if
she's not welcoming if she's not
hospitable if she's gonna judge you and
be angry at you and hate you
then yeah protect yourself and keep
yourself safe
but the idea of if she didn't want any
of my beliefs then i don't even know man
that's an exhausting front to keep up
diane isn't it
it is it really is and it feels tiring
and so what i've landed on i'll just
tell you in my life i've i've vacillated
across
a number of different this is just the
way this is and i've done it with diet
and nutrition and with exercise and with
religion and with faith i've dealt with
all of the stuff man i'm i'm as annoying
as it gets
and ultimately where i found wisdom and
more importantly where i have found
peace
both in my values and in my beliefs and
more importantly in my relationships
is
i keep my values deep
deeply ground into the core of the earth
and i keep my beliefs held really
loosely that's why i read that's why i
hang out with smart people that's why i
have conversations that's why i go
bowling that's why i have to grab a beer
with somebody because i want those
things to change and evolve over time
and i
set the rest down
because i want my life to be about
hospitality and entrance and sometimes
after we've run for our lives and we
find ourselves safe we have to re-learn
how to open the door again
and you sound you sound angry diane are
you angry
i won't say that i'm
angry but i but i noticed that with her
wanting to be closer that that i get
stressed okay and so so so i called you
because i did notice that that my ego it
is kind of um kind of raging some song
i need to work on meeting meeting her
where she is because there are so many
people like her in this world and i and
i have to keep striving on work on
learning how to work with people period
you are brilliant and strong and
beautiful i love it i love it i love it
i love it
so
meeting her where she's at
starts with you
absolutely defining
your boundaries
okay it will be a great exercise for you
to write down here's what i believe
about the following
i believe this
i believe this and when somebody
somebody challenged me to do this about
a decade ago maybe a decade and a half
ago
i was not nearly as certain as i thought
i was as my flexin
thought it was
i was like
except i'm pretty sure about this and
what ultimately underneath the ideas
that i was quote-unquote super sure of
i developed a robust
i'm relatively certain
i'm open for new ideas and i will
preserve relationship at all costs
and it was the focus on relationship
then i could say okay what do i need to
be in relationship i need someone who's
going to be equally curious equally
inquisitive equally not a maniac
and equally fun and laughed laugh-filled
and that's why i've had people of all
sorts stay at my home spend the night at
my house play with my kids their kids
play with my kids because i'm now i'm
seeking hospitality
in connection truly above being right
you know what i mean and that starts
with what do i believe so i want you to
write that letter to her and then invite
her into a conversation and tell her
i know you've been reaching out i'm
nervous about this
be honest keep no secrets and you will
walk if she says i can't be a part of
you either you're in my religious
cult sect thing or i can't have a
relationship with you
you'll at least know right you know what
i mean
and you'll walk away with you'll be sad
but you'll be at peace which i think is
what a gift right and if she does she
says i'm all in i miss my sister
then she calls your bluff would that be
cool tell me that would that be cool or
would you be more annoyed
like like you read her this letter i
don't believe this i don't believe this
you guys are still doing this and it and
i can't be a part of this here's who i
am now and i miss my sister i want you
back but here's the terms it's going to
be under and she said
oh diane i've been waiting for you to
say this for 25 years i'm all in
i'm all i know we have different we dif
we differ on things we're gonna parent
differently we're gonna solve problems
we're gonna love different all that i
get it but i'm all in i'm your sister
would that make you weep with joy or
would you be like no i want you to run
away
how would that feel
well i want to say what i think i will
feel and at the same time i have to
acknowledge that because it hasn't
actually happened yet that it that it
isn't real but i think that for her
that i would end up reaping with joy
hearing that from her oh wow huh
so here's what i'll tell you as the
great esther perel says all relationship
is a risk
and
uh marriages that are 50 years old is a
risk every morning and brand new i just
met you and i got the butterflies in my
stomach that relationship's at risk too
risk with our family members our
brothers and sisters and moms and dads
are such a risk relationships with our
kids such a risk
and you are worth that risk and so is
she
you're worth that risk
and can i tell you this
you
have
done so much heavy lifting you're gonna
be surprised at how strong you are
like i i'm i'm i can't my my gratitude
for you is overwhelming
because you've been on a hard journey
and most of this you've done alone huh
yes i have no one no one has joined me
john so it's been me hey can you grieve
that for a second
that stinks man that's hard
it's lonely yeah and nobody went with
you and they should have exactly
and
i get mad when i get angry it's usually
my body trying to respond to sadness
loneliness
like y'all should have called me i
wanted to go to watch the fights you
don't even call me
and i get mad but really my mad's
covering up dude i just sat at home by
myself and listen to my dumb chickens
right
or you're in dallas and it's like man
i've been on this spiritual journey and
this existential journey and i've been
reading and learning
all by myself
where are y'all you know what i mean
and i think sitting in that for a second
is important
not that it's going to drum up rage
against your sister but just it puts
your body into a more honest position
with itself right
and as as brene brown says man shame eat
secrets for breakfast so moving forward
we're going to enter into this we're
going to try to re-enter into this
relationship no secrets
just love just boundaries just
straightforwardness no secrets
because diane you're worth being a
sister too your sister's worth having
sisters and my hope is that y'all can
reconnect even if you all have feet in
different places y'all can reconnect
will you give that letter and that that
that personal meeting a shot
i will thank you all right last word you
ready
yes practice
have you heard me say this on the show
yes
yes john and so i so i've been in
toastmasters for eight years so i will
tell you that i cherish and i look
forward to practice and i know how
critical practice is so yes i'll make
sure that i go through that confronting
practice no no no no that's not that's
not even what i'm talking about okay
number one you've been at toastmasters
which is a whole other level of
incredible
but but listen
you're gonna have to practice
asking for forgiveness
and you're gonna have to practice saying
you're sorry you have to practice saying
hey
you're starting to evangelize me again
and i just want my sister
and she's gonna go oh okay yep yep yep
yep
and
she's gonna invite you to church at her
church that you don't care for and she's
gonna be doing out of a place of
hospitality and love and you're gonna
have to remember oh yeah yeah it's cause
she loves me and you can say no thank
you i'm not i'm not i'm not gonna be
able to make that um but thank you for
inviting me you're gonna have to
practice being
a 40 year old sister
got what i'm saying because the
when you've gone through a season of
deconstruction you your radar gets
finely tuned to anybody with different
thoughts anybody who's pressuring you
anybody who might have hurt you in the
past
and you're gonna have to learn to detune
that sucker down because you're
re-entering into a relationship that
you're going to have to practice it's
been a long time
it has it has so i i've been going from
my hometown well over half half of my
life
so
yeah it's um it is very different for me
whenever i go visit family oh dude yeah
and they dump you back in the old roll
right away right
and
oh dude yes the worst the worst the
worst
um
but man hey i'm so proud of you
incredible incredible
work you've done
now it's time to practice reconnecting
which oh it's gonna be tough with your
sister here's what i think's gonna
happen i think you're gonna read that
letter i think you're gonna write the
letter
and you're gonna weep more than you're
angry
because i think a part of writing that
letter but here's what i believe and
here's what y'all put me through as a
kid and no one's came and got me i think
there's a lot of sadness in there and i
think there's a lot of loneliness in
there
and then i think reading to your sister
it will be a love letter of here's me
for 20 years you haven't known me here i
am
and there's going to be something
exposing about it something super
uncomfortable about it because you're
coming you're standing up and saying
this is me this is who this is what i
believe this is who i am this is how
i've grown this is how i've ungrown
right
and it's going gonna be exposing and
then you're gonna look at her and say do
you still love me you know everything
about me now do you still love me
and my gut tells me she's gonna reach
across that table and y'all are gonna
hug like you haven't hugged in a couple
of decades that's my hope that's my hope
you're worth the risk
thank you so much for the call diane
we'll be right back
hey delonay here one of the things i
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloni.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
and uh with the one and only john legend
people have told me i look like you've
been seeing and play the piano almost
identical to him
and by people i mean no one's ever ever
said that they've never confused us he
may be
he may be the best looking guy on planet
earth and then he sings and it's like
god wait man
john legend she doesn't have to know and
it goes like this
oh stealing moments just to be with you
though it's wrong it's hard to tell the
truth no
she don't have to know she don't have to
no
when i meet you i got my shades on to
cover up my eyes just to cover up my
eyes i'm hoping that nobody sees me
passing by
through my disguise i still know you
recognize but you i know you got a
little secret of your own
yes you do you know it's wrong sneak it
out on me while your man's at home you
know you're wrong but it's still so
strong still carrying on
[Music]
i'll see what you did there jenna well
done
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode insider
baseball do y'all trim your eyebrows
every once well if i have to but rarely
i've got a large forest growing atop my
eyes right and so i i do
every once in a while when i'm getting
like at a barber he said trim your
eyebrows and i was like sure and as he
started trimming them i literally
started laughing like he took so much
off i can run faster but now they're
growing directly forward i can let you
borrow some of my eyebrow gel
you're officially on friendship
probation effective immediately kelly i
just have a question about my sneaky
snakey 12 year old
you have the only sneaky 12 year old in
the whole world she takes my clothes she
takes my makeup including my eyebrow gel
i'm gonna put a hard no on that one you
gotta draw the line somewhere sarah and
that's it